I think the real problem is when science
became incomprehensible right
like like to the Layman well yeah like
the Hadron colliders just too
complicated for the someone I understand
yeah that's scary you look at something
like uh let's say quantum theory or yeah
you look at like string theory and
people yeah I don't know what the [__]
this is yeah man really well you just
need to hire intellect so you need to
watch a lot of them I didn't watch Rick
and Morty so I don't properly understand
but you get into like quantum theory
where
um you know it's you know they are doing
things with
stuff that's like my explanation of it
and the Hadron Collider is that your
explanation of course yes then doing
things with stuff okay okay explain to
me how this makes sense logically right
whatever the [__] uh the cat what the
uh
where something is both alive and dead
at the same time okay which is quantum
field Theory I can explain this as
someone who was this close to going into
quantum physics in uni okay and you
became a YouTube and then I became a
YouTuber
I really fell off I nearly became an
award-winning artist I just didn't I I
became unemployed yeah so Schrodinger's
cat is this idea that the Universe and
every decision that is made in the
universe runs on what is called a system
yeah okay and please correct me in the
comments if I'm wrong about this but I
thought you're asking me I'm like
this is all you man
but basically it's based basically it's
like if a state of being has two or more
conclusions right which say for example
yes there is you know this like cheese
board for example has the conclusion of
being face up like this or it has the
option of being face down like yes those
are two different states yes right but
in reality what we see is just one of
those States this thing is currently
face down yeah right Schrodinger's cat
is this thought experiment of there's a
cat inside of a box that is enclosed
um I think schroding originally did it
with like some chemicals Einstein did it
with a stick of dynamite but basically
because
I'm crazy
but basically there is a box that has a
cat and something or device that can
potentially kill the cat and they close
the box so they can't see inside the box
right there is a 50 chance that in
Einstein's case the dynamite will
explode and kill the cat or there is a
50 chance that the dynamite will not
explode and the cat is alive but because
the box is closed right now you don't
know what state the cat is in right both
States exist at the same time but
quantum physics state that this cat
right now is in a what is called a
superposition which is where it is both
alive and dead at the same time right
because the system has not been closed
we all know so the closing of the system
in this case is when Schrodinger
Einstein opens the box to see if the cat
is either dead or alive not both
so now here's the question the question
is
what box is Schrodinger inside of that
made him close the system of opening the
box or closing it
Flat Earth in it
so there was this idea of well schroding
is like okay well I've determined my
actions have determined this system in
one way or another but what is
determining my system to be one way or
another what is what is what is creating
my reality
and that's the whole idea of Chinese cat
I think
I studied this I might be completely
wrong but that's my understanding of it
and it's very fascinating when you like
look into it because then you start to
look into multiple dimensions and string
theory and uncertainty principle and all
this kind of [__] yeah see like you've
you've already lost corner and like
partially me in that like conversation
so imagine like the average flat earther
yeah you know which you know have you
have you seen like the map like the Flat
Earth Map dude it looks badass
it looks like a Lord of the Rings map
yeah this is like Tolkien level of World
building man [__] you know man let's
write a book no one like like if you
haven't seen this map like flat authors
have made a map of like what is beyond
kind of like what we can see like yeah
there's like the end of the Earth like
what's beyond the end of the Earth right
and it is like some [__] Game of
Thrones level of World building it's
sick
yeah legit
other boys good together
good morning
don't [__] with the Flat Earth you don't
[__] with the flat [__] with it why why
I just I just the thing for that boggles
my mind with the Flat Earth is it like
you could have chose anything to get
invested in and the one thing you
decided to give a [__] about is
disputing that the Earth is a ball
like you could have gotten into like the
cia's poising in our minds or something
which is kind of like wild but at least
out there yeah you really chose the most
boring conspiracy theory of the earth
not only the most boring but the most
proven to be wrong yeah it's like it's
like uh it's like picking your favorite
TV show unlike Rugrats it's like really
is nobody's favorite show